[Music]
you might have heard about Google cloud
functions which makes it possible to
write simple single purpose code that
scales automatically and runs in
response to events you might also be
wondering does it work with go cloud
functions recently announced support for
Python 37 and no D and today we're
excited to show you the newly released
go support for cloud functions let's get
started go cloud functions come in two
distinct types HTTP functions and
background functions let's take a look
at an HTTP function first HTTP functions
run when they receive a request and they
return a response the function signature
follows the HTTP handler func interface
from the ghost standard library meaning
that you can use the wide variety of go
HTTP middleware right out of the box now
let's deploy it we give our function the
name hello
specify the entry point F and add the
trigger HTTP flag once it's deployed
your command line will show the URL you
used to trigger the function just copy
that in your browser to test it and with
that we've just employed our first go
cloud function next let's take a look at
a background function while an HTTP
function responds to a request a back
run function responds to an event let's
write a function that triggers every
time a cloud storage buckets contents
change here's what our function looks
like it receives a cloud storage event
and logs the file and bucket name
deployments function is just like
deploying an HTTP function we give our
function a name specify the entry point
and specify the event type and resource
that originates event now with all the
setup complete this function will fire
every time a new file is added to our
bucket don't forget to create the cloud
storage bucket before deploying your
function now the test this just use a
web UI and upload a file to your bucket
we've only shown a very small piece of
what's possible with go cloud functions
with cloud functions you don't have to
worry about server management you only
pay for what you use and your functions
scale automatically in response to
demand best of all you're using the
familiar building blocks of go functions
using go cloud functions you can build
mobile or IOT backends virtual
assistants or chat BOTS do real-time
file processing or integrate with
third-party services just to name a few
what's best though is that it's
incredibly easy to get started by
writing a small function and go and then
building it up from there we hope you
give a go cloud function to try I'm you
know Compton and I'm Angela let us know
how it goes by leaving questions or
comments in the section below reach out
to us on Twitter and don't forget to
subscribe to the Google cloud platform
YouTube channel for more go buddies see
you next time thanks for watching